ses affiches de campagne se succèdent
dans les rues poussiéreuses de kampala
chapeau blanc sur la tête seul au
président sortant ou gandhi yuweri
museveni est une nouvelle fois candidat
à sa réélection
après 35 ans au pouvoir le chef de
l'état apparaît encore comme le grand
favori du scrutin
accusée de réprimer l'opposition il a
une dernière fois interpellé ses
adversaires à la télévision c'est
malheureux mais inévitable il n'y a
aucun moyen pour que quelqu'un vienne
jouer avec notre pays décider de ce qui
est bon et ce qui est mauvais si c'est
le cas nous allons l'arrêter nous ne
pouvons pas accepter cela
sans les nommer le président ougandais
fait référence aux dix candidats qui le
défi pour ces derniers la campagne a été
mouvementée entre arrestations menaces
et 100 sur des réseaux sociaux
le principal rival du président
ougandais l'ex chanteur bobby wine l'a
directement accusé de vouloir faire
taire toute contestation
comme vous le savez tous mesdames et
messieurs s'opposait au général mous
sévigny est un crime plus dangereux que
tout autre crime que nous connaissons
ici en ouganda alors que nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui
les enlèvements les tueries et les
arrestations se poursuivent
c'est donc une élection particulièrement
tendu qui attend les ougandais dans ce
contexte
nombreux sont ceux à espérer que le
scrutin ne dégénère pas depuis ma
naissance ce sont les élections les plus
tendue dans le pays car la plupart des
gens paniquent maintenant dans les
villages ils ne connaissent pas le futur
je pense que le gouvernement devrait
parler et expliquer aux gens que pendant
et après les élections il y aura la paix
j'espère que les élections déboucheront
sur la paix car c'est notre pays et nous
n'allons nulle part ceux qui ont de
l'argent sont partis mais oui les
pauvres
nous sommes restés dans les villes
cet appel au calme est également partagé
par l'onu et les états unis qui appelle
les autorités ougandaises à respecter
les droits humains
de son côté la commission électorale
demande aux différentes parties de ne
pas perturber l'élection
en conclusion la commission exhorte
toutes les parties prenantes à se
comporter de manière tolérante pacifique
et tranquille
nous les appelons bras à participer aux
activités finale de cette élection
conformément aux lignes directrices et à
la loi afin de garantir un vote libre et
équitable cette présidentielle sera
couplé à des élections législatives
près de 18 millions d'électeurs
ougandais sont appelés aux urnes lors de
ce scrutin